et pour parler de cette nouvelle
mobilisation concernant la réforme des
retraites michel taube fondateur du
cygne opinion internationale est avec
nous sur ce plateau michel taube 11
jours dont je vous remercie d'avoir
accepté notre invitation directe sur rt
france un peu plus de 10,1 % de
grévistes à la sncf d'après la direction
dont 35 % de conducteurs et conductrices
un chiffre en hausse par rapport au
début de semaine est ce que cela
signifie un regard de la mobilisation
qui pourrait encore durer
je pense que la mobilisation est parti
pour durer parce que de toute façon le
le compromis que le gouvernement a
proposé aux syndicats ne visait pas les
grévistes ne visez pas la cgt dans ton
bien l'entendre le secrétaire général
visait surtout la cfdt et et l'opinion
publique donc effectivement le dialogue
de sourds va continuer on a deux
entêtement qui sont l'un en face de
l'autre on a un gouvernement qui peut
avancer qu'il l'a dit et redit avec un
projet de loi qui va être adoptée au cou
s'est mise le 24 septembre et de l'autre
des grévistes qui continue qui se
battent qui ont du mal parce que
économiquement ça devient difficile mais
on le voit dans les rues de paris
et pas qu'à paris à des mobilisations
d'autres villes de france
continuez donc effectivement je pense
que l'enlisement dans lequel on est
rentrés l'enlisement laquelle on est
entré il est malheureusement parti pour
durer
vous disiez un dialogue de sourds mardi
le président de la république s'est
exprimé à pau en marge d'un déplacement
sur cette réforme
je le cite un quand on prend la peine
d'expliquer et d'écouté on peut lever
beaucoup d'ambiguïtés qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire que ceux qui
défilent aujourd'hui n'ont pas pris la
peine d'écouter le président la
république hier à l'heure des voeux à la
presse à l'elysée a aussi dit que le
moment venu il s'exprimerait aux
français c'est pas si ce sera en
conférence de presse ou dans une adresse
à la nation
non je pense que le
le projet de réforme des retraites est
très compliqué mais les fondamentaux
sont posées ont été dit et redit par le
premier ministre je pense que les sont
deux modèles qui s'affrontent deux
modèles qui sont assez claires un
système par répartition actuelle que
veulent conserver avec quelques
modifications les syndicats comme la cgt
et ceux qui veulent faire une sorte de
révolution avec un système universel à
point
toujours par répartition mais calculé
autrement le présent république a parlé
de 60 millions d' âge pivot qui serait
un peu la solution vers laquelle on
irait mais en fait c'est exactement cela
ce que propose le gouvernement c'est en
fait 66 millions de régimes spéciaux
c'est à dire une individualisation du
parcours de retraite pour chacun d'entre
nous sur arte france voulait prendre
deux journalistes qui ont l'un qui bosse
cinq ans alerté france et l'autre qui va
bosser dix ans ce je vous le souhaite
une longue vie et la retraite ne sera
pas les mêmes à la fin de votre carrière
parce que vous serez passé dans la même
entreprise c'est une autre manière de
concevoir la retraite et ce sont deux
modèles qui s'affrontent qui s'opposent
et sur lesquels effectivement quand je
parle de l'entêtement c'est parce qu'en
fait derrière il ya deux modèles
différents qui s'affrontent et donc je
pense que des deux côtés
et puis j'ai envie de dire les syndicats
ils ont aussi beaucoup à perdre
je les ai mis dans un édito que j'ai
publié ce matin qu' un petit peu
provocateur mais il est vrai qu'à la
ratp
et c'est là qu'il ya le plus de
résistance les
les chauffeurs de la ratp ont beaucoup à
perdre parce que dans le système actuel
ils ont droit à une retraite qui est
évalué à plus 3000 euros par mois donc
l'enjeu pour eux est très important donc
cet entêtement réciproque
il va durer et je pense effectivement
qu'on n'en a pas fini avec ce mouvement
de gad l'an déplaise au premier ministre
de la république est est ce que après
six semaines un peu plus de six semaines
de grève selon vous tout a été fait de
part et d'autre pour tenter de débloquer
la situation où le dialogue de sourds il
existe depuis le début alors un le
dialogue de sourds existe depuis le
début pour la raison que je disais ça il
ya deux modèles qui s'affrontent et
chacun des deux partis veut des
fonctions ce modèle et deux en même
temps il ya des cons premiers qui ont
été faits notamment par le gouvernement
mais dès le 19 décembre lorsque le
premier s'était exprimé avant avant les
vacances
et ces concessions ne satisfont pas la
cgt mais ont quand même satisfait de la
fiabilité puisque laurent berger qui
demandait à ce que lâche pilot à 64 ans
soit soit retirée ou suspendu l'a obtenu
la stabilité a accepté de discuter avec
le gouvernement d'un mode de financement
différent du système de universel à
point donc il ya des compromis qui a été
fait d'autres aboutir et puis quand même
c'est quand même en cas dans un drôle de
situation on en est à 43 jours de grève
sur un projet qui n'a même pas encore
été adopté en conseil ministre et qu'il
n'en est donc qu'à ses débuts il va y
avoir encore des mois de discussions au
parlement avec des discussions sur le
mode de financement en parallèle donc on
est loin d'en avoir fini et je pense que
l'enlisement et c'est vraiment ce que je
moi je retiens de cette semaine
finissant tu sais que effectivement on a
pas fini avec ce conflit
il risque de durer alors qu'il ya
d'autres chantiers de deux enjeux qui se
posent à notre pays
mais là-dessus manifestement c'est parti
pour durer encore un certain temps pour
conclure quand on a deux parties qui
s'entête un en face de l'autre qu'est ce
qui finit par gagner
en général vous qui êtes un fin
observateur aulas
moi je remarque que depuis 2005 et la
crise du cpe le contrat première fois
les syndicats ont toujours pas perdu les
combats qu'ils ont menée l'année
dernière la cgt sur le statut la sncf a
perdu et c'est comme ça depuis
maintenant déjà plus de dix ans et donc
il ya des évolutions profondes en
société on a des syndicats qui ne sont
pas assez représentatifs pour peser sur
le débat public
je pense que le chef de l'état pour lui
d'avoir une majorité absolue à
l'assemblée nationale donc il aura le
dernier mot en terme de jeu
institutionnel
donc effectivement moi je crains pour
les syndicalistes gouvernement ait le
dernier mot
mais après voilà c'est un rapport de
force
on est aussi dans un deuxième épisode de
cette colère françaises qui avaient
commencé avec le gilet jaune qu'on
revoit sur les retraites et qui va
peut-être avoir un troisième épisode
autrement sur d'autres enjeux
fabre est fondée sur un quinquennat qui
est difficile qui est un président très
déterminé et des français qui ne
comprennent pas toujours et qui qui
ressent clinical air assez importante
merci beaucoup michel taube d'avoir
accepté notre invitation à faire
partager votre analyse sur notre plateau
je rappelle que vous êtes fondateur du
cygne opinion internationale